اجرى وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي اف جلنت جوله
تفقديه للقوات الاسرائيليه في منطقه
خانيونس جنوب قطاع غزه وقال جالانت ان
الجيش فكك قوه حماس في خانيونس وانه
سيستكمل عملياته في المدينه ثم سينتقل
جنوبا الى رفح واضاف ان الضغط العسكر
سيشكل ضغطا على حماس كما سيساهم في اعاده
الاسرى المحتجزين في
غزه الانون كتيبه خانيونس التي تباهت
بانها ستقف ضد قوات الجيش اصبحت متفكك
واقول لكم من هنا سنستكمل المهمه في خان
يونس وسنصل الى رفح وهناك سنقوم بتصفيه كل
مخرب يحاول الحاق الضرر بنا وساقول لكم
امرا اخر العمليه العسكريه التي تقومون
بها بالنيابه عنا وتقترب فيها من العدو
تحت الارض وفوقها هذه العمليه تقرب اعاده
المختطفين كل يوم فحماس لا الا بالقوه
وعندما تضغط عليهم اكثر سياتون
ويتحدثون